your big break came on Sarah not live
and what they probably don't know is the
night that you found out that you got on
sir net 11 you were actually gonna be
joining the cast something bad happened
to you that same night yes I was having
drinks with my sister and her husband
and Tribeca and I was in such a good
mood as you it just I mean Lauren
Michaels had just told you you're gonna
be on the cast I yes I believe I believe
it he had just told me it was all right
I just met with him
you know what I just met with him I
didn't know officially but we had a
really good meeting so things were
looking good and I was kind of
celebrating with my sister and her my
brother in LA we had a glass of Pinot
Noir and I was like and then I went down
on the street and I got mugged I got
thrown down by a really guy like hard
like boom like thrown on the ground like
my demonstration yeah yeah and I didn't
know what you were talking about it you
got up and did that yeah that's uh
that's really scary yeah I was scared
but I was in such a good mood from
meeting Lauren that it didn't bother me
at all I was like oh my god I'm being
mugged positive attitude about it cuz I
was flying high and I just I nothing
could get me down even even being thrown
on it cement Street in New York City and
he just asked for you know he's like
give me all your money and you know
gimme gimme and then uh I was like okay
sure sure but I remember thinking this
is so weird I'm just gonna be like water
and blend into and not fight him back
and then he I said oh here do you want
my coat and then he was like no that's
okay you can keep a coat so we had I was
like oh he's sweet so we had like a
minute yes I was instantly bonded to him
right right and I realize that could
happen that fast yeah
[Laughter]
you